fun fact of the day guys um so
this is this one's a random one actually
the g
yeah i couldn't get my words up the g
spot was almost called
the whipple tickle
after it was discovered by dr beverly
whipple
so hence the whipple tickle but dr
whipple decided to name it
after dr ernst graffenberg the first
person to propose the existence of the
uniquely sensitive region
hence the g-spot
cool man yeah what is the g-spot really
about
it's in terms of what in terms of i know
what it is
also you know i know where it is right
but like what is it actually about like
not in terms of like
biologically or anything like that but
it's like um how do i explain it
maybe a gaydon needs to hit me up
because obviously
i know what women say about it and
obviously guys have one
up the pooper so it's about
the sensitive area a sensitive area but
like
um so for example i've had loads of
conversations with women in the past and
and it always comes down to this anal
chat in it
just like uh what would you do like if a
girl wants to put a finger up your arse
or something like that
and i'm always like obviously it's a
night and then their rebuttal is always
um
the g-spot is up there i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm good
i'm actually fine like i've been doing
all right so far for
that i don't feel like i'm missing out
yeah i mean but then
i don't know maybe a gaydon might hit me
up and just be like bro fam
you're missing out
my eyes are widened my eyes are wider or
i swear swear tell me more
oh exactly that's what that's when
that's that's the question i'm asking
what's it all about okay
he might hit me up like fam you are
missing out
my eyes roll back tell people tell me
more
because apparently it makes you not i've
heard it makes you not
and i've been nutting just fine midnight
that's what i do
ah but yeah it could be a it could be a
vibe i don't know i'm not even willing
to experiment just someone tell me yeah
let me know and i'll let you know from
there whether i'm gonna next because i'm
i'm fine
as it is yeah it's similar to like um
how do i how do i explain it what's
something that people preach but i'm
like i'm fine
um i don't know maybe like
something to do with the ocean i hate
the ocean maybe like
um like scuba diving is one thing for me
people are it's unbelievable like it's
life-changing you have to try it
and i'm like i'm actually good like i'm
fine
but maybe it would take someone who's on
my level yeah who hate sharks and hate
this
to hit me up and i know they're on my
level and be like james
trump you don't know what you're missing
it's the most unbelievable experience
that's what i need yeah i need a donnie
who is maybe even a gay i wouldn't even
be the right example i need a guy who's
just been out here
busting nuts in pum is not interested in
that i need you
that's what i need it's what i'm getting
at i need you to tell me
what's going on for this is
you need to get your someone to stick
your finger i was shivering
that's what i need to hear james i was
against it but now i'm all for it
just nothing like that ah i'm shaking oh
my god i said i need you his wish
on that level where i can be like bet i
i agree i i understand like i believe
you
i truly well and truly believe you
that's what i need i couldn't go first
i couldn't go faster you'd have to go
first i'm not going first
i'll be scared i'm ticklish
i'm ticklish so i could it's one of the
things i couldn't know it's gonna happen
that day oh yeah rags it it couldn't
have been
like tonight is we're gonna test this
g-spot thing tonight no i'll be scared
all right
coming over it's just done you've just
certified i'm not coming over
yeah it has to be a sneak attack but not
a surprise like
you know what i mean it has to be like a
smooth it has to be she has to be
all up in my like my balls
before i know it it's in there we're
there we're there and there's not much i
can do
yeah because there's been times where
it's close to have not necessarily
a finger up there but like the tongue
area
yeah where she's she's been all up in
there sloppy top bubbles galore
and she's just going lower and lower and
i'm thinking this could be the day
someone licks my ass